[Musique]
et jacqueline govou qui est à dreux
justement quel est le constat que vous
faites en matière de mal logement est ce
que les choses s'amélioreront pas là on
a eu 1 on a un quartier qui s'appelle
les bat qui est 9 heures donc il est en
rénovation il va il va avoir des
bâtiments cassé mais non en attendant
ces personnes qui sont dans des
appartements où il ya des ouvertures de
3 4 cm l'appui rentre où il ya des
punaises ou iliad et enfin des blattes
enfin c'est quand même incohérent que
c'est pour les gens il reste
et puis les enfants vivent dans cette
humidité où ils sont atteints sur poumon
vraiment c'est dramatique ça c'est un
quartier en particulier deux et c'est
quelque chose que vous voyez un problème
que vous voyez augmenter ou finalement
qui arriva à la trouver des solutions il
n'y a pas que des bailleurs il ya du
privé ou là cette année j'ai jamais eu
autant de maisons ou d'appartements qui
était indécent ou qui étaient à salubre
ou des murs tombent et carrément c'est
ça fait peur et moi je suis responsable
au niveau national et je pensais que
c'était dû à ce petit monde parce que
voilà il y avait eu beaucoup
d'industries qui en a plus maintenant
non c'est ça existe ça roule ça existe à
marseille ça existe à dijon c'est
partout la difficulté elle est là les
tensions
voilà un quartier en parler au salaire
de l'insalubrité qui a mené aussi à des
drames on l'a vu
[Musique]